how do you know when a writer is holding
back so let's say i bring to you
what i think is a traumatic scene and
you read it and you say
yeah it sounds traumatic but i'm not
like it's missing d something's missing
here
when they write more about okay so when
they write more about the other person
in the scene than them
that's how i know they're holding back
they're not talking about themselves
they're taking that other person's
inventory
and it's more about that other person so
i'll say well this isn't a book about
that person
how did you feel in that situation
that's a number one example
you can actually see it before they even
start writing the book
typically um they'll a client will come
to me
this isn't i don't mean typically in
this situation this is how it unfolds
i've got all this other writing that
i've done and i'd love for you to read
it all because i think i want to include
it all in the book
and i'll go well how much of their of it
is there and they'll say well i mean
it's like a couple short stories i wrote
i think
there might be some nuggets in there and
i think oh we're never going to use any
of this but i think well
i'll read it right because i'm getting
to know them and it's
it's almost like part of the process
because they're saying to me this is who
i was before i came to you
will you look at me right so they are
actually giving me an opportunity
to see where they're going to have to go
from and i'll read the material and i'll
either
i'll glean from it they're this kind of
writer or this is what's been important
to them
we never use that material because i
see that they're going to like i see i
get a good idea i'm like okay this is
i understand where they're starting from
i understand why they're coming to me i
understand why they're showing me this
they're saying and a lot of times um the
material will have
pretty graphics in it and they've spent
a lot of time
presenting it um when they write books
with me i'm like
do not put any graphics in the book
while we're writing it it's just
something we have to delete
move around it's just it's technical
stuff words
just words don't dressing it up
is not gonna change my edit notes like
i'm gonna come
i'm not you're not gonna like fool me
with the pictures right
um and so that's one way that i see that
they might be
uh like a little more resistant to being
honest
i had a client once who wrote an entire
book with me
for two drafts
and it was at the end of the second
draft
i don't i don't know if i missed it or
she just threw it in
kind of like slid it in but
it i read it and i realized that
something had happened to her as a baby
in a crib
it was abuse and
she hadn't even realized and she didn't
even realize she'd written it
and that was that was
painful that was that was it was
it was it was hard to call it out and it
was hard for her to process it
so i think if you want to tell
it'll come out right whether you know it
or not
whether you know it or not the words
kind of they don't lie
that'll be the truth it's like freudian
slips
very true how common is it for a writer
to not believe in themselves
i mean does anybody ever really believe
in themselves who's a that are
that is a writer i mean i have days i
think it i think it
varies from day to day i i
think that um one thing i've been doing
lately
is i'm part of a writing group and we
will write
and read out loud and nobody will
say anything you just read and it's
thank you
um and then another part of that group
which is more of an
advanced group we will read a chapter
and then the group will comment on it
and i think that that takes away when
you're able to
present and perform you
get out of that headspace that i'm all
alone and
on any given day it's all about me i'm
either good or i'm bad
good or bad it's hardly ever
well that was a good day it's it's never
in the middle i think as a writer you're
either
or you're amazing so when you are in a
group and you're reading to other people
you realize that there's a lot of good
things about your writing
there's some things that need to be
fixed about your writing oh i didn't
expect that person would like that oh i
really like how i sounded oh well i'm
writing about all these
gosh i keep using that voice wow i'm
really snarky there's so many other
things to think about
versus good or bad and that's where i
try to get writers to work from
like what are your strengths what are
some of the areas you could improve
um if that's not something you're very
interested in getting better
then maybe we'll have someone come in
and do maybe like some edits on that for
you
or you know uh but rarely does anyone
say oh i'm not i'm not a good writer i
think they're pretty
pretty proud of themselves by the time
they get through three drafts if
anything they're very proud of the
work they just did week after week
there was the the vigilance and the
resiliency
no matter what to sit down at that
computer
and write a chapter even if it's
something they want to just
throw against the wall in absolute
disgust
you know i've had them turn in chapters
and
say well i'm turning it in
dot dot dot you're like you know the
rest of that sentence
is but i think it's terrible and it
never is
what about the flip side those that
think it's amazing and actually
maybe they're not seeing themselves and
i mean
it's they're blinded by something that's
a great question
i do um no experience i i have had
experiences like that where
they're on a journey and you could you
could just be their guide
so you can tell that a lot of what
they're writing
probably belongs in a journal and
might need some more extensive therapy
before it goes out in the world
it's definitely a little bit of a dump
maybe a little bit of a show um
but that's not my i'm not a j
i'm not going to judge their experience
so if they're done with it
and they say and i might say this felt a
little
hard are you sure you want to come out
and say that about like
your mom or that ex-husband or like you
know i know we're going to change some
names but
that just was that's whoa
that's real you're going for the jugular
on that one i know
that's who they're gonna be and i don't
i am
i am you know hats off to you
like i've given the disclaimer um
because what will happen is is that
they'll go out and try to sell the book
and a lot of times with a little bit of
my guidance depending on
whether they're still coaching with me
or not but they'll go out and i've
become friends with most of these people
at this point so
i am i have a lot invested emotionally
with them but
they'll find out sooner or later because
someone will say this feels like
an emotional dump and then they'll have
to go
you know maybe i should like get rid of
that one scene
with the you know and some people need
more of a rewrite
and they don't have time or money
anymore to do a rewrite so they might
have to sit on it for a while
so if it feels really heavy if i'm like
whoa this is not i'm not moved but if
this is almost like uncomfortable for me
then maybe it is this dump is is that
how yeah it's not really for the reader
it's for the writer still and you want
to get it to a place where it's
for the reader to then have their
experience and feel like
uh i just heard someone say that like
angela's ashes he wrote that for 10
years or something because
he wanted to write it until he wasn't
angry anymore
so that the experience could be for the
reader
what is your process for coaching belief
into someone well i always just say the
fact that they signed up for a one-year
program and they're showing up every
week
is already pretty amazing
and really impressive um i'm always
giving like positive notes like love or
that was amazing or look how you turned
that around
or this is incredible in my one year
program there isn't
a lot of time to not believe in yourself
it's so rigorous and it's so continual
that i don't really think it's belief
that trips them up because once they
start getting going they just
want to do the work and finish it
because they're committed
i think belief falls more into uh
people that aren't there yet right so
that would be more in the own your
authorship class
that's people who you know it's a lot
more like
cheerleading and a lot more showing them
the light
of the vision that they have that they
can get to the finish line that they are
worthy of writing
uh that they just they desi you know
they
they can have that desire as much as
anybody else can have that desire
so there's a lot more coaching belief in
i would say the uh in those early
early foundational and fundamental
classes
but my one-year clients they're pretty
badass
they they signing up for a one-year
program
and and and putting out twenty thousand
dollars you already better believe
because you're invested does anyone get
scared
because they know people will read it
and they may identify
they may even though names are changed
and think but they're just afraid even
you know
yeah it's traumatic to divulge secrets
i've had clients sit on their books for
a little bit longer than i thought they
should have but that was their process
that they needed to go through and then
when they did actually release the book
they were ready
um and so they're ready you know when
they're ready
um or they had to like the book had
shown them something about themselves
and so they had to go be with that new
self for a little while
and then maybe start a podcast or open
another version of their business
and they knew the book was good so it's
not like it was getting stale
they knew that they could bring it out
when they felt like they were in a in a
successful space
and so sometimes that might be six
months after they're done
um after a year i start to
to hassle them what happened to your
book what happened to your book what
happened to your book and some people
it doesn't happen much anymore but in my
early days of coaching there were people
that wrote the book just to write the
book
they they were done they were like i'm
good something i wanted to do in
retirement
i don't really think i have time and
energy to go through the whole
publishing process
i'm really happy i did it i feel like i
wanted it down on paper for legacy
and i just don't think i need to publish
it
sometimes i've seen comments that when
someone's written about let's say a
famous parent
that whatever the public's perception of
that
individual is they end up getting mad at
the at the writer
because maybe they're divulging things
that we don't want to see that side of
that person right have you ever talked
about
you know the the criticism that could
come for
divulging secrets or speaking about
whatever
oh yeah isn't seen as honoring
whomever i like to say if you're getting
that kind of criticism
you're doing well with your book because
nobody criticizes a book nobody cares
about
so i believe to get that level of
criticism
you have to have a lot of eyeballs on
your book
a lot of eyeballs on your book to kind
of
kick up that kind of you know dissent
about it right that many people have to
be reading it so i
i look at that as kind of a win it's
like good they're fired up
tell more people to read it because
they're going to be fired up and they're
going to be upset and
i haven't had anybody write about
anybody famous
um i do have a client who wrote about a
lot of
there were hollywood people in it she
hasn't published yet
um but she wasn't
she was like that's the way it went down
and i was there so it's not like
contestable really because it's exactly
what happened
and there were witnesses so um
you know we don't like in general our
bubbles burst if that
if that's the bubble it's going to be
burst for you and you chose that book to
read it maybe you were looking to get
that bubble burst anyway you just don't
know it on a subconscious level
you